ok tenemos por aquí dos polinomios que
se están sumando y nos están pidiendo
que los simplificamos que ahora para
empezar aquí tenemos estos paréntesis y
un más en medio y pues de hecho nos
podemos deshacer de esos paréntesis
porque en realidad no está afectando
para nada al segundo paréntesis ok y una
vez que nos deshagamos de esos
paréntesis lo que vamos a hacer es
agrupar todos los términos que tengan el
mismo grado por ejemplo vamos a agrupar
todos los términos que tengan x cuadrada
y le vamos a sumar la agrupación de
todos los términos que tengan x y luego
todos los términos que no tengan x ok
entonces pues empecemos por deshacernos
de esos dos paréntesis vamos a volver a
escribirlo todo aquí esto es 5x cuadrada
más 8 x menos 3
y ahora más este más de aquí dos equis
cuadrada y bueno de hecho si este en
lugar de ser un más hubiera sido aún
menos entonces hubiera tenido que
distribuir el menos en cada uno de estos
términos aunque yo hubiera quedado menos
2x cuadrada y luego menos menos 7x y
finalmente menos 13 x pero pues es un
más entonces nos queda 2x cuadrada menos
7 x más 13 x y ahora pues tenemos que
escoger alguna de las potencias de x
podemos escoger x al cuadrado y pues nos
vamos a buscar todos los términos de
éste bonche de términos que tengan x al
cuadrado que éste tiene x al cuadrado
éste no éste no esté también tiene x al
cuadrado y éste tampoco y tampoco
entonces los agrupamos tenemos 5 de esta
cosa que es x al cuadrado más 2 de esa
misma cosa pues entonces tenemos que
tener 7 de esa cosa que es x al cuadrado
bueno entonces vamos ahora con la
siguiente potencia de x tenemos por aquí
8 x menos 3 no tiene x estos dos pues
tienen x cuadrada en lugar de x entonces
obviamente no lo vamos a volver a sumar
y por aquí tenemos menos 7 x
y 13 x aunque entonces aquí le tenemos
que sumar 8 x menos 7 x + 13 x que
finalmente es 8 menos 7 y nos queda 1 y
luego más 13 entonces nos queda 14 x y
finalmente buscamos los términos que no
tienen ninguna equis y pues el único
término con esa forma es este de aquí
así es que nos queda menos 3 podemos
pensar en este menos tres como en x a la
0 porque cualquier cosa del acero es 1
entonces nos quedaría menos 3 x x a la 0
que es igual a menos 3 x 1 que es menos
3 pero pues es simplemente el término
constante ok el chiste es que ya
terminamos de simplificar esta expresión
y listo